[Music]
recently we started a brand new website
conan dot triple x now ladies and
gentlemen
this is a real sight tonight we have
another conan triple x video to premiere
okay
it's called big dick little chicks
enjoy
all right once you have a seat
okay
thanks for doing this
all right
you comfortable
um yeah pretty comfortable okay
uh what's your name
my name is will hi will
um
how old are you will
i'm 45. okay great that's great we got a
lot of uh
45 year olds in here that's great um do
you know why you're here
um
yeah i think so
uh
yeah you're here to be a dick yeah
yeah i could yeah
have you been a dick before
yeah i have um
my friends tell me i'm a pretty good
dick sometimes so yeah
all right so you're a pro you're a pro
already
oh i don't know about that all right
well here's the situation will uh we
happen to have a bunch of baby chickens
right here okay uh we're gonna bring
those in let's bring those in
and uh what we're gonna need you to do
is be a dick oh they're these chicks
they're baby chicks all right yeah yeah
they want to watch you uh
go ahead
okay
uh
hey
hey yourself
yeah you guys smell terrible
you guys look soft it's good because i'm
gonna wipe my butt with you
yeah
oh there's a great part at the end where
they think he's dead but he's not oh did
i spoil that for you oh sorry
you're so dumb your iq's a triangle just
a basic shape hey check it out guys
it's a picture of your mom
huh
you see that
yeah that's your mom
hey what's up mom hey
[ __ ]
thanks
hey
shut the [ __ ] up
who wants a mcnugget
anyone
what's so wrong why are you crying
huh what's the big deal
you want one
[Music]
[Applause]